uh hi now i'm back again
and um here i'm going to show you what i
i'm going to try to speak louder i think
the sound was a bit too soft on the
first video
uh here is a lesson that i have imported
from radio prog
we have sound here
again i'll demonstrate the sound so you
can hear
hear the sound
cheshire says
so
now i wish that my voice came out as
loud as that but obviously here you can
download it so i could save this if i
hadn't already saved the sound i can
save the sound i can listen to it while
i'm reading through it i can go back i
can find a different spot on the sound
bar
and so forth now the main activity at
link in a way is linking and what that
means is you're going to words that you
don't know which are these words in blue
there's 120 new words for me in this
text
the white words are words that i have
previously passed on that meant that i
either didn't notice them or felt i knew
them
sometimes we will come across them and
we in fact don't know them and i mean
this is influence as far as i remember
have an impact on but let's just look it
up again in case i forgot impact so i
can always save it again and the
statistics will adjust but i'm going to
pass on it so i'll just leave it
uh or i can actually uh yeah it won't it
won't
count when i
or i can say no
for that matter i can say it's not
but what i tend to do is i often
also the yellow words are words that
i've looked up before
the ones with only an underline are
words that i have actually moved to
known
okay these are words that i've moved to
known
the different shades of yellow indicate
their status just how far along they are
in progression to known
so
the number one task is to get rid of the
blue words and i can either go through
them one by one and here often you have
to edit them because
google translate gives me the word
afraid
i know that it's not afraid
i can look it up in the dictionary which
takes longer or i just assume that i
know
and i go in there and i just edit that
and say not afraid
so the other thing i could do but i'm
not going to bother i could tag it but
i'm not interested right now because i'm
not working on verbs i'm working more on
noun cases
so i can save that
and
here again global
now cheshire says
so are not overly concerned about the
influence of the in
the um you know global financial crisis
on the domestic economy is what that
says so what i try to do now is
even as i'm saving things
uh
i try to figure out what might be the
case
uh
now here i'm not entirely sure what the
case is quite honestly
uh so the dopamine
they don't afraid the influence i'm
assuming that would be a genitive of
so for the fun of it i will call that
genitive
and later on i might get better and say
no it wasn't the genitive it was uh
you know the instrumental
in fact it could be instrumental i'm
confused so i'm going to maybe cancel
and not not uh
attack this all right
now uh not doma
domaci economico
uh
to
now
z this i know
this is the
november
report
of this newspaper
so there i'm assuming that that is the
genitive and so therefore i will save
this phrase
and also
tag this as genitive
add okay
so then i go through and then okay
now here again i know that word it's
it's one of these words that you just
pick up answered incidentally i could
tag that as the uh instrumental case and
and the reason i tag this
is because later on in the um in the
vocab section
uh i can then
go and grab a list of all the words that
i or phrases that i have tagged as
instrumental and then i get to see them
which is very useful
uh the other thing i could do is rather
than going through the text
sometimes i'm in a hurry
uh oh well i'll get back there in a
hurry to get this to the ipad where it's
more comfortable to sit and do it so i
could hit the quick link
button
and that enables me to go through all of
my blue words
immediately okay
so i go down here previous i know that
maybe i'll grab this one again i tend to
over link because if i'm even doubtful
about it i'd rather have it in there
as a word that i can review there's no
harm in having more words
uh so and so forth so that's how i would
go in through and do that i can then go
back to my standard view
it's easier to link phrases in the
standard view
these are the instructions which i don't
need so i can close them
um the other thing i was going to
mention is one thing that i find
uh very useful which i'm uh linking a
tagging for right now
is these um
these uh uh sort of what i call
connector words see now pack i've
already saved that and tagged it as
connector
um
let's see if there's another one here
you know chiba also for example is a bit
of a connector word so i would tag that
as a connector and add that all right so
i'm accumulating a bunch of words
that uh you know even this you know
i think okay it's i think but we often
want to say i think maybe even mislim
and so that becomes uh you know mislimit
and i edit that and when i edit it i tag
that as a connector because
these are the words that you need very
often when eventually you get to where
you want to speak
so to summarize
i go through here typically i will quick
link get through my blue get through my
blue words
then i go back in and i will highlight
any phrases that i need and i will go
back in and tag i will also sometimes
tag
uh
right in when i save the blue word if i
wanted to here i could take these words
all the yellow words are listed here and
i can do flashcards with them and so
forth
so what i tend to do is get on here work
the text once or twice have some sense
of what it means
download it
and then i listen on my ipod or i yeah
and uh i then have to read it again
because i can't understand it very well
when i listen to it
so i go to my ipad where this lesson
appears the sound appears
all the yellow words i can simply touch
with my finger and see the meaning so i
kind of work this
mining it for words and phrases not with
the expectation that i'll remember them
but with the expectation that over time
continuously doing this more and more of
the language is going to speak
for those of you who are new to link you
can go to the tutorial view and there
you have very deliberate specific
instructions step by step on what to do
so that you uh you know you figure out
what to do obviously
um
yeah i think that's probably enough
uh the next session
if this works out the next one that i
will go to oops now i got my thing stuck
here is vocabulary
and i'll show you what i do at the
vocabulary page but that'll be for the
next one so thank you for listening i
hope that this is useful